[Aplausos]
[Música]
en 2017 se cumplen 70 años desde que la
india rompió con el imperio británico y
se convirtió en un país independiente
siendo hoy por cierto la democracia más
grande del mundo en estos 70 años la
india ha conseguido hacer funcionar un
sistema político con más de 1000
partidos con una alta participación
femenina y que es totalmente inédito en
un país tan pobre
[Música]
claro que amigos de visual político no
lances todavía las campanas al vuelo'
esperar porque no se puede decir que en
estos 70 años de independencia las cosas
le hayan ido muy bien a este gigantesco
país de más de 1.200 millones de
habitantes la pobreza la desigualdad un
perverso sistema de castas y muchos
muchísimos problemas con los derechos de
la mujer han sacudido a este país
durante estos últimos 70 años
[Música]
eso y cuatro guerras con pakistán que
hasta ahora ha sido algo así como su
archienemigo
pero bien si realmente queremos ver
porque decimos que la india no puede
sacar pecho por estos últimos 70 años
nos bastaría solo con comparar la
evolución de este país con la de china
por ejemplo fijaos cuando deng xiaoping
lanzó en china su política de apertura
al mundo y cambio de modelo económico
allá por los años 80 los tamaños de las
economías de estos dos colosos china e
india- eran similares en 2016 sin
embargo el pib chino fue cinco veces
superior atentos a este gráfico
[Música]
y no sólo eso mientras en china el
analfabetismo afecta a menos del 4 por
ciento de la población en india casi una
de cada 3 personas no saben leer ni
escribir si echamos un vistazo a
cualquier otra estadística los
resultados van a ir en la misma línea
teniendo en cuenta todo esto casi
podríamos llegar a la conclusión de que
lo único bueno que ha conseguido este
país ha sido su democracia verdad pues
esperad un momento porque parece que
todo este oscuro panorama de pobreza e
injusticias está empezando a cambiar
[Música]
cada vez más expertos apuestan por que
el siglo 21 va a ser sobre todo el siglo
de la india es decir que durante las
próximas décadas vamos a ser testigos de
cómo este país pasa del tercer mundo a
convertirse en toda una potencia
económica muchas empresas como amazon y
apple apuestan por esta transformación y
están prestando mucha atención a este
mercado y es que entienden amigos que si
se cumplen las expectativas en los
próximos años podríamos ver uno de los
mayores negocios de la historia
[Música]
no se trata solo de las empresas el
propio gobierno nacional indio tiene
unas expectativas muy altas para los
próximos años en nueva delhi la capital
confían en que la transformación del
país sea tan importante como la que
china ha vivido en las últimas décadas
de momento sus objetivos para los
próximos diez años son importantes el
gobierno aspira por ejemplo a construir
seis nuevos macro puertos 250
aeropuertos oa impulsar atentos más de
150 millones de viviendas nuevas y
accesibles en otras palabras todo apunta
a que podemos estar a punto de ver el
gran despegue de la india que bien
verdad pues tener presente una cosa en
pekín no piensan lo mismo para nada
[Música]
de celos y desconfianza
china es el principal socio comercial de
la india sin embargo a pesar de ello las
autoridades chinas están mirando con
mucho recelo la creciente capacidad
económica política y militar de la india
en un momento en el que china quiere
ganar influencia política consideran que
la emergencia de india no es una buena
noticia para sus intereses y es que
amigos en pekín saben bien que la india
no es un rival más para nada mirar
algunos analistas afirman que la india
ha superado ya a china como el país más
poblado del mundo y desde luego el resto
ya tienen claro que si no ha ocurrido ya
ocurrirá en menos de una década ojo
porque por culpa de la política del hijo
único que estuvo muchos años vigente en
china la población india tiene y tendrá
más jóvenes y menos ancianos toda una
ventaja la india es tal vez el único
país de asia con la suficiente capacidad
potencial como para hacer de contrapeso
al poder político de china en la región
after working ahora no penséis que este
sentimiento se queda solo en los
despachos para nada esta creciente
rivalidad tiene también su reflejo en la
calle tal vez porque ha sido un mensaje
alimentado por sus gobiernos o tal vez
porque la competencia nunca es
bienvenida lo cierto es que tanto los
indios como los chinos lo tienen muy
claro sus respectivos vecinos son sus
grandes rivales atentos a los datos
según una encuesta de 2016 del pew
research center tan sólo el 26 por
ciento de los chinos tienen una opinión
favorable de la india por su parte los
indios no se muestran mucho más
optimistas con sus vecinos en este país
apenas uno de cada tres ciudadanos tiene
una impresión favorable de china además
por si no fuese suficiente siete de cada
diez indios están bastante preocupados
por el empuje militar de pekín y
consideran que la influencia económica
de china en su país no es nada positiva
[Música]
bueno de todas formas hay que decir como
curiosidad que a pesar de todos estos
números bollywood empieza a gustar en
china este verano por ejemplo hemos
visto como dacal una superproducción
india arrasaba en las taquillas chinas y
se convertía en una de las películas con
mayor recaudación en china de todos los
tiempos eso sí no penséis que esto es
algo intrascendente no este incipiente
éxito de bollywood tampoco ha gustado
nada a las autoridades chinas que la
verdad empiezan a estar un pelín
obsesionadas y ven en la influencia
cultural otra grave amenaza en términos
de poder blando la india lo ha hecho
mucho mejor que china aunque la economía
de la india no está tan desarrollada han
puesto un gran énfasis en promover su
cultura de todas formas ojalá todas las
tensiones se viesen en un terreno tan
como decirlo pacífico
desgraciadamente la realidad no es así
[Música]
disputas en el himalaya
mientras todo el mundo miraba a
pyongyang y la crisis nuclear en corea
del norte ocupaba todas las portadas de
los medios de comunicación otra crisis
política estuvo a punto de hacer saltar
chispas
ocurrió en pleno himalaya a más de 4000
metros de altura en el que tal vez sea
uno de los lugares más remotos de la
tierra la meseta de do clave en este
lugar entre los meses de junio y agosto
se vivió una de las crisis políticas
entre china e india- más serias de los
últimos 55 años cuando tropas del
ejército chino invadieron el norte de la
india veréis el pasado 8 de junio de
2017 un pelotón de guardias fronterizos
chinos y un equipo de construcción
entraron en este territorio que está en
disputa entre china y el pequeño y
cerrado reino de bután otan el país de
la felicidad nacional bruta si el mismo
que por cierto un día tenemos que hablar
de él aquí en visual político pues bien
el caso es que las unidades chinas
destruyeron varios búnkeres utilizados
por el ejército real de bután y
empezaron a construir una carretera
bien conforme a varios acuerdos en vigor
desde los años 40 la protección de bután
le corresponde a la india así que el día
16 tropas indias llegaron y bloquearon
la construcción de la carretera bien
hasta aquí un típico conflicto de
fronteras empezando por que a bután este
terreno inhóspito le da un poco igual
[Música]
sin embargo la tensión lejos de diluirse
fue a más y la discusión entre pekín y
nueva delhi se puso tensa las
declaraciones se fueron calentando e
incluso los medios estatales chinos
amenazaron al gobierno indio con graves
consecuencias
y la india están peligrosamente cerca de
un conflicto militar en el himalaya pero
llegados a este punto puede que os
estáis preguntando por qué diantres se
le concedió tanta importancia a un trozo
de tierra que prácticamente se pasa
congelado la mayor parte del año bueno
por un lado parece que el gobierno de xi
jinping quería probar a la india en un
minuto veréis a qué me refiero y también
castigarla por bueno por muchas cosas
por su relación con el dalai lama y el
tíbet por sus crecientes vínculos con
washington por advertencia etcétera
etcétera y respecto a la india porque el
control chino de esta zona con presencia
militar y la nueva carretera le pondrían
a china a tiro de piedra del llamado
corredor de siliguri una estrecha franja
de terreno considerada estratégica
porque conecta siete estados del noreste
de la india con el resto del país en el
mapa lo podéis ver bien
[Aplausos]
y sobre todo más allá de cuestiones
tácticas por otra importante razón la
misma por la que china quería probar a
la india en un minuto
veremos de qué estoy hablando el caso es
que finalmente el lunes 28 de agosto
tras muchos tiras y aflojas muchas
amenazas y mucha tensión las dos partes
acordaron retirar sus tropas y regresar
al punto de partida de todo este
embrollo político
eso sí hacía años que la rivalidad entre
ambas potencias no se visualizaba de una
forma tan clara y por supuesto amigos no
nos engañemos esta meseta de do clan es
lo de menos y no lo digo sólo por los
más de 3.000 kilómetros de frontera con
muchas disputas territoriales entre
china e india- hay muchas más
[Música]
una estrategia regional
ante la posible emergencia de la india
como superpotencia el gobierno chino ha
adoptado una estrategia rodearla tal
cual como lo escucháis en los últimos
años china ha estrechado lazos con
pakistán a cambio de 60.000 millones de
dólares en infraestructuras
especialmente para conectar a ambos
países incluyendo un estratégico puerto
en guardar que china operará por cierto
hasta al menos el año 2050
[Música]
por otro lado una empresa del gobierno
chino se ha hecho con el control del
puerto de hanban tota en sí blanca país
con el que pekín también está
estrechando lazos políticos respecto a
bangladesh china se ha convertido en su
proveedor de armas más importante el año
pasado sin ir más lejos le vendió dos
submarinos y por ultimo nepal que tras
un conflicto político en 2015 con nueva
delhi ha mejorado mucho su relación con
china bien ahora fijémonos en el mapa
[Música]
veis la india aparece rodeada
si la india no hubiese sido firme en la
defensa de los intereses de bután y de
los suyos propios en la meseta de
docklands hubiese sido toda una
advertencia sobre la poca fiabilidad de
este país y puede que china hubiera
conseguido otro tanto con bután esta es
la estrategia de china para frenar la
tentación india de convertirse en un
actor regional influyente bien como os
podéis imaginar chinas tienen la
capacidad económica el dinero para hacer
amigos con una gran facilidad y desde
luego el hecho de que la superioridad
militar china respecto a la india sea
aplastante también ayuda así que una
pregunta que surge aquí obligatoriamente
es visto todo esto cuál es la apuesta o
mejor dicho la respuesta de la india
básicamente dos palabras estados unidos'
sí así es
[Música]
en los últimos años las relaciones entre
eeuu y la india se han estrechado mucho
entre 2009 y 2016 el comercio bilateral
se duplicó y la venta de equipos
militares de eeuu a la india se
multiplicó por 50 de hecho como ejemplo
de esta creciente asociación todo apunta
a que la india va a sustituir sus viejos
1.021 por más de 200 f-16 de nueva
producción
y ojo porque la intención de lockheed
martin el fabricante es trasladar toda
la producción mundial de este avión
desde texas a la india una forma
inmejorable de estrechar alianzas no os
parece pues bien ahora ya podemos
entender mejor no sólo las tensas
relaciones entre china y la india sino
también la estrategia de china o la
nueva estrategia de mano dura de eeuu
hacia pakistán
[Música]
[Aplausos]
eso sí todo lo que hemos visto parte de
una premisa y esta es que en la india
conseguirá emular el éxito económico que
china ha conseguido en las últimas
décadas narendra modi el popular primer
ministro indio del que ya os hemos
hablado en este canal vegetariano
soltero y practicante de yoga modi es un
político que escapa al perfil
convencional procede de una familia
humilde y de niño ayudaba a su padre a
venderte en una estación de tren está
liderando muchos cambios pero no tantos
como el país necesita pero esto lo
dejaremos para otro vídeo ahora turno
para ti
crees que china conseguirá doblegar a la
india déjanos tu respuesta en los
comentarios y también en esta encuesta
si te ha resultado interesante el vídeo
dale a like y no olvides suscribirte a
visual política por cierto si quieres
conocer mejor el poder que tiene china
no te pierdas este vídeo un saludo y
hasta la próxima
[Música]